-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
Alright! That's really good,
for a Thursday.
Let's get to the news.
President Biden announced
sanctions
and other measures
against Russia today,
in response to cyber attacks
and election meddling.
Well, you have made
a powerful enemy today.
No, no, no, the other one.
Yeah, there you go.
President Biden
announced yesterday
he will withdraw all U.S. troops
from Afghanistan
by September 11th and said
"It's time to end
America's longest war,
but don't cry
because it's over, Dick.
Smile because it happened.
President Biden met
in the Oval Office today
with the Congressional
Asian/Pacific American Caucu
to discuss diversifying th
administration. Said Biden -
[ As Biden ]
That's perfect,
because I actually know
a great Hawaiian guy
I would love to hire.
[ Laughter ]
Just keep getting his voicemail.
Vice President Kamala Harris
said yesterday
she will travel
to Guatemala and Mexico
to address the ongoing
immigration crisis.
She intends to find out,
once and for all,
how people like Ted Cruz
keep getting back in.
[ Laughter ]
House Minority Whip
Steve Scalise
brought a milk carton
to the Capitol yesterday
with a picture
of Vice President Kamala Harri
and the caption "missing at th
border" on the side.
It's kind of the perfect
punishment for him
that he had to spend all day
explaining the joke.
"You see When kids went missin
in the '70s, they would --
No, I'm not making fun
of missing kids.
You know what? Never mind.
I shouldn't have done it.
Never mind.
Infectious disease expert
Dr. Anthony Fauci
testified today before the
House Select Subcommittee
on the Coronavirus pandemic,
which the Democrat-led panel
has entitled,
"Reaching the Light
at the End of the Tunnel:
a Science-Driven Approach
to Swiftly and Safely
Ending the Pandemic,"
and Republicans are calling,
"Question Time with Dr. Fakey.
[ Laughter ]
Democratic lawmakers today
introduced legislation
that would add four seats
to the Supreme Court.
Of course, if they do that
you know Clarence Thomas
is just going to sleep
across three of them.
[ Laughter ]
Toy company Mattel
announced yesterday
they've banned
over 400 racial slurs
from the board game Scrabble
which really
won't affect my game,
unless this is a racial slur
[ Laughter ]
Netflix announced yesterda
a partnership
with the meditation app
headspace,
to create a new series that will
teach subscribers how to sleep
Yeah, pretty sure my wife
already made us watch that one
I said what I said.
[ Laughter ]
Producers have released
a trailer
for the newest installment
in the "Fast and the Furious
series,
called "F9: The Fast Saga.
Interestingly, if you hit F9
on your computer,
it will write another
"Fast and Furious" screenplay.
[ Laughter ]
Today was International
Pizza Cake Day
and I know they say
it's international,
but, I feel like
it's just American.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, today was alsho --
was also -- excuse me --
National Ask an Atheist Day.
The other 364 days are
They'll Tell You Anyway Day.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody.